hi there steve kaufman here um today i
want to talk about
what teachers often get wrong
now
uh i know a lot of very good language
teachers
i'm talking to two of them
check tutors via skype
some of our best tutors at link are
teachers
lots of teachers get it right
but i wanted to mention
where i think they get it wrong some of
them maybe many of them i had a comment
from a person called riva
on my most recent post about the meetup
in prague
and she i'm assuming it's a she
said that
she wishes that she had spent more time
listening and reading and developing her
ability to understand czech and to enjoy
the language rather than
doing what she needed to do to pass her
tests
and the teacher for example insisted
that they learn
certain czech proverbs
okay now that's just one example
i am not the slightest bit interested in
proverbs
when i learn a language i don't know
proverbs i don't care about them but
there's nothing wrong with proverbs
if the teacher is interested in proverbs
that's great
but why would the teacher insist that
the student has to know and learn these
proverbs
and then be tested on them
to me that's just plain ridiculous
uh it's far better for the student to
spend his or her time
on
things that are of interest to the
student in fact proverbs are not very
important at all
if we look at the real goals of language
learning which are
comprehension and communication
the same is true with a lot of the
grammar tests that students are given
fairly early and in fact throughout
their
period of study in many cases as is the
case in our school system in canada
people are tested on the subjunctive in
french and things of that nature
or on their tenses
again i have to say when i start
learning a language i'm not that
interested
uh i'm kind of aware that there are
issues
in the slavic languages with cases there
are issues with verbs of motion i read
the explanations i vaguely understand
what they're getting at
i'm vaguely conscious of it as i read
and listen in the early stages but i
wouldn't want to have to be tested on it
i wouldn't want to have to get it right
some people may want to do that so then
that's fine
but why should the
student who is learning something that's
of interest to him or her in other words
the language and where the ultimate goal
is to understand what is said
and to be able to communicate
why should that student have to dance to
the teacher's tune why should the
student have to
write tests on proverbs or on
you know
colors or
or subjunctive or whatever the teacher
chooses to test the student on to me
it's meaningless
and i've said it before i've seen the
products of english language instruction
excuse me french language instruction
the english school system in canada and
the results are abysmal
i posted my efforts in czech and some
person said that that i'm already better
in czech than many of the people
who study the language
maybe it has something to do with the
fact that i enjoy
my check i enjoy it so much that i
listen every day and i listen to things
of interest and i read things of
interest and i build up my vocabulary
and now
that i have all of that i'm starting to
focus more
on
the fine points of grammar so that my
usage
gets better but for the first 10 months
i wasn't speaking the language so as
long as i can understand more or less
and i say more or less because i'm quite
happy to half understand or 80 percent
understand
uh but i'm enjoying it
as long as that all is happening and i'm
gaining experience in the language well
isn't that really good enough now you're
going to say well yeah but you can't do
that in the classroom because you have
to have a curriculum and i say why do
you have to have this curriculum
can't they come up with some other test
you know uh
to try to of course the teachers want
some test that is objective you either
know the proverb or you don't know the
proverb you either uh put the right
tense down or you don't put the right
tense down so you've got something that
is measurable
it's a little more difficult to say this
person understands this person
communicates well it becomes more of a
subjective
measure
so there is a problem i admit there's a
problem but
the solution in other words trying to
force students to learn what the teacher
taught to learn things that the teacher
thought were interesting
things that the teachers thought were
interesting or to learn in the order
that the teacher wants the student to
learn
i think in many cases that discourages
the learner and delays
the
arriving at the ultimate goal which is
the ability to communicate and to
comprehend
so
whether
those thoughts of mine have any
relevance to the classroom or not i
don't know but i couldn't help
wanting to
you know talk about it when i saw this
message or this comment on my video from
riva saying that in her czech classes if
i understand correctly
the students are asked to
you know be able to reproduce
czech proverbs which struck me as
completely ridiculous
uh not that prophets are ridiculous but
insisting that students who may have no
interest in proverbs like me still have
to reproduce proverbs struck me as
ridiculous anyway thanks for listening
bye for now